antoine pour l'instant pas d'annoncé à
proprement parler de cette conférence
qui a donc lieu en ce moment même
mais que faut-il attendre de ce rendez
vous entre emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine
oui pas encore d'annoncé mais on le sait
les premières images sont tombés
l'entretien entre les deux hommes est en
train de se dérouler à l'heure où l'on
parle et les deux hommes devraient
parler en particulier du fameux dialogue
stratégique entre les deux pays un
concept qu'a tenté de relancer emmanuel
macron l'année dernière au mois d'août
dernier lors de la venue de vladimir
poutine au fort de brégançon depuis la
dir poutine s'est rendu deux fois en
france à paris plus exactement une
première fois le 30 septembre pour les
obsèques de jacques chirac et une
seconde fois le 10 décembre à l'occasion
du sommet au format normandie qui tente
de trouver une issue au conflit qui
paralyse l'est de l'ukraine
l'ukraine il devrait donc en être
question ainsi que différentes
autre thème en particulier des questions
sécuritaires plutôt au proche orient on
pense en particulier à la syrie ou de
nouvelles sanctions américaines viennent
d'être mises en place pour mettre la
pression encore davantage sur bachar al
assad même si c'est bien la population
syrienne qui risque d'en souffrir le
plus et puis il ya peut-être le dossier
le plus chaud du moment la libye où
l'egypte fait planer le spectre d'une
intervention militaire sur place donc on
peut voir les sujets ne manquent pas les
sujets de discussion ne manquent pas
entre les deux hommes pour cette
rencontre d'aujourd'hui
merci antoine claireaux pour l'ensemble
de ces précisions direct de moscou